vous avez la possibilité le 6 décembre
de vous exprimer n'oubliez pas d'aller
voter pour les régionales nous sommes
dans la dernière ligne droite le 6 ce 13
décembre il faut absolument se mobiliser
tous ensemble les républicains les
centristes nous sommes rassemblés pour
que dans nos régions enfin la droite et
le centre assument à la fois leurs idées
et les mettent en œuvre concrètement sur
le terrain il n'y aura pas d'alternance
il n'y aura pas de victoire nationale en
2017 s'il n'y a pas d'abord une victoire
une reconquête territoriale pour ces
régionales le 6 décembre
vous avez une occasion unique de dire à
la majorité socialiste sortante votre
mécontentement et votre volonté de
préparer l'alternance le 6 décembre vous
avez l'occasion de refuser le désordre
que représenterait l'arrivée du Front
national à la tête d'une des grandes
régions de France les régions c'est les
lycées c'est l'université c'est
l'apprentissage c'est le développement
économique c'est la formation
professionnelle des chômeurs ce sont
donc des leviers très importants pour
ramener la croissance dans notre pays et
aussi pour ramener l'emploi offrir une
espérance et une alternance défendre
cette France des territoires depuis son
monde urbain jusqu'à sa ruralité la plus
éloignée la mobilisation de tous c'est
nécessaire pour aller se battre pour ces
régions c'est donc le moment d'aller
voter je vous appelle vraiment chacune
et chacun d'entre vous à vous mobiliser
le 6 décemb dans
c'est le rendez-vous du nouveau souffle
6 décembre nos candidats ont besoin de
votre soutien de votre participation et
de votre espérance l'alternance est en
marche
rienar